gosh his face only  [Music]  and crown a good we  Brotherhood from sea to sea  [Music]  I wanted to do this Sunday Charlie liked  this song he liked the song because of  the sentiment what it says and do it  pays tribute to there was no more  genuine or ardent supporter of our  military than Charlie James I thought  I'd die an old man back in my hometown  they gave me this plot of land  being some other man for a job well done  there's a big white house it's all a  huge and stuff the road if you believe  differently than he did that was okay  but he wasn't ashamed to tell you at any  given time how much he loved the Lord  and I always respected him so much for  them  we failed  schmegle  girl singing women come on  me  Shangri  how sweet  the sound  [Music]  just a few more weary days and me  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]